McDavid at the 101 cafe and then he
asked me to the podcast and then when I
saw I saw it was as if like two old
souls were back together because of the
fact that all sukira and I met when we
were she was 17 years old
whoa yes yes she was living in New York
and she was working laugh factory and I
was and I wasn't I couldn't draw then
right like I knew Jamie Masada the owner
of the Laugh Factory but I couldn't sell
any tickets that's not true though you
were you were on MADtv I know that's
also why the [ __ ] do we have to pass out
flyers that you know what it wasn't you
it was a club because they had just
opened you were like one of the first
people to headline there and it was like
this I don't know if that Club was like
empty every single night it was and so
they were like let's try this new thing
since we have Bobby yeah where they had
me for some reason and Bobby passing out
flyers to the show seven did you work
there as a waitress it was a hostess so
I just seated people okay but she was a
kid I was a kid it'd be 21 weird high
school your hostess maybe I was you were
young little if I was seventeen I guess
I was and I remember we did this little
ride and some of them do we do right
yeah we ain't Mexicans I remember that
yard and then I remember thinking I
remember this like really specifically I
remember thinking that Bobby was the
first person I ever met in my life that
was like everything you do was funny
like if you like if you just like picked
up a fork that was hilarious and I had
never met anyone like that cuz I never
knew any comedians or and I mean I was a
kid like I didn't know anyone in comedy
so I remember thinking like wow like
that exists for naturally
[Music]